welcome back costumes and Border
Protection reporting more than 2 million
migrants have illegally crossed the
southern border for this fiscal year
last week was a complete disaster
joining me right now with more is
Republican presidential candidate Larry
Elder Larry thanks very much for being
here I want to talk to you about the
issues of the day and I know you wanted
to communicate this on the debate stage
next week but you're not going to be
there are you
well I hope to be there I won't know
until Monday at 6 PM Pacific Time
whether or not I've met the criteria I
need to be a three percent or a better
uh in three different polls I needed to
be at one percent or better in three
different polls in order to qualify for
the first debate I got shafted at the
last minute Ronald McDaniel calls me and
said you can't use one of the polls
because it's affiliated with Trump
referring to the Rasmussen poll
Rasmussen said we're not affiliated with
Trump so I don't know what I was
supposed to do I got shafted I'm very
angry about that but
what are you going to do if given the
chance about the wide open Southern
border last week was a complete disaster
on Wednesday and Thursday we saw 10 000
migrants uh enter this country they are
entering the country they are getting
processed and then they are being
released into the country many of them
are going to New York and other big
cities that's why Eric Adams is out of
control upset about it let's take a look
at these pictures if we can show them of
last week Thursday while you tell us
what your plan is
well my plan is to reinstate the Trump
policies On the Border uh if it weren't
for these Governors from Texas and
Florida sending these illegal aliens to
Blue cities uh it wouldn't be covered by
CNN wouldn't be covered by MSNBC they're
now finally starting to cover it and
even people on the left are beginning to
get very upset about this California is
even a bigger Sanctuary State uh that's
why I've written a book called as goes
California my mission to rescue the
Golden State about what people like
Gavin Newsom and the single party
Democrats have done to a state like
California where people are leaving for
the very first time California is even a
worse State when it comes to coddling
illegal aliens Gavin Newsom has expanded
the amount of illegal aliens who get
taxpayer paid health care and on and on
and on so we need to stop this from
happening to our country yeah and Gavin
Newsom might be the opponent of
President Donald Trump no no no no no he
won't
Larry Elder was with me this morning
stay with us all right
welcome back and we are back with
Republican presidential candidate Larry
Elder Larry I want to show you these
latest polls uh Washington Post ABC news
reporting that President Trump is now 10
points above uh Joe Biden in a
one-on-one head-to-head race your
thoughts on the 2024 election will
anybody be able to cut into president
Trump's lead here
I don't think so people are worse off
than they were two three years ago the
borders are insane and this business
about Gavin Newsom coming in all of a
sudden are you kidding me Maria their
first Democrat Primary in South Carolina
60 of the voters on the Democratic side
are black most of those are black
females and they love love love Kamala
Harris and if it is perceived she's
dropkick for a white dude I like Gavin
Newsom black women will they won't vote
Republican they just won't vote thereby
guaranteeing whoever our nominee is he
or she will win the nomination you play
by you live by the gender and race cars
you die by the gender erase card they
cannot afford to drop Cape Kamala Harris
they are stuck with her if Joe if Joe
Biden can fog up a mirror what about
this idea that the Democrats are going
to uh roll in Michelle Obama at the end
of the day
uh ask Karma Harris if she wants to be
rolled out for Michelle Obama she ran
for president she wants to be president
the only way she can go is she says you
know what I'm so incompetent I'm out of
here she will not do that they got a
huge problem it's called Joe Biden their
second problem is called homely Harris
and they're not going anywhere all right
we'll leave it there lari Elder thanks
very much 2024 presidential candidate
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else